okay let's bring out Nancy she's a
history professor at Duke University and
author of democracy in Chains the deep
radical history of the radical right
self planned for America Nancy MacLaine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can bring that home with you okay so
we've been going on and on about the
trouble the country's in but you've
written a whole book about it and I
think you would agree with some of our
panelists here that it's been going on
longer than Trump right yes I would say
thank you and I meant to yeah this feud
that he was sort of having with the Koch
brothers I know you've written a lot
about the Koch brothers it's really
funny isn't it because they're basically
on the same page wouldn't you say yes
it's a tremendous distraction I have
been studying Charles Koch and the plan
that he's been developing and the ideas
that they've weaponized for over a
decade now and I have learned one thing
which has never pay any attention to any
individual play and instead look at the
long game
that he's playing once you understand
that long game and you understand the
strategy you can get a better sense of
what the pieces are and what to
anticipate a case in point is this
suddenly we're seeing signs of light
between them all the other things that
been nothing to upset Charles Koch all
the horrors that we've seen in different
places nothing about what happened at
the border etc why now why now because
they are this close to getting Brett
Kavanaugh a coke selected Supreme Court
justice on the court just in time to
affect what Coke is actually seeking
which is in the language of the
architect whose ideas he's weaponized
who I studied in my book James Buchanan
the first u.s. southerner to win the
Nobel Prize in Economic Sciences changes
in our Constitution so radical as to be
called a constitutional revolution they
want to transform our Constitution in a
radical and fundamental way and we are
all being distracted by the president's
tweets while this is going on but and
that's so crazy because the people who
need the Constitution changed are the
Liberals it's we're the ones it's not
working I mean you mentioned the Supreme
Court the Supreme Court should be seven
to two liberal because four of the
justices were appointed by two by Bush
and how to by Trump two presidents who
lost the popular vote this is what I
mean
the Electoral College works for them so
so what what do they want that they're
not getting now yeah I actually have a
little history lesson a little civics
lesson toward the end of my book where I
point out that our Constitution is
already the most restrictive of
majoritarian democracy in the world we
have what are called four veto for
what's called veto points we have for
most people have one maybe two maybe
three we have four so these guys are so
essentially greedy that they want to add
more veto points to what we have what is
a veto point what do you mean so so
things like the electoral college right
like the capacity of the Senate to veto
etc but what they want to actually put
into effect is instead of a constitution
of checks and balances as we have now a
constitution of locks and bolts and
while we're all distracted by Donald
Trump's tweets the network that Charles
Koch is funding groups like the American
Legislative Exchange Council have been
lining up authorizations for
Constitutional Convention
they now have 28 of the 34
authorizations needed to call the
first-ever Article five constitutional
convention since our Constitution was
crafted and they have ten Liberty
amendments they call them teed up and
ready to go and we haven't been paying
any attention at all with exception of
groups like common cause well what are
the ten amendment what it what's like
the top two horrible ones yeah okay so
this an example of how like folks on our
side could be a little bit more curious
and stop thinking that we know
everything and actually the other side
stop right right because some of these
there's a book that was a best-seller on
the right that none of us have heard of
called the Liberty amendments that goes
into this and you can google them but
they include a balanced budget amendment
which polls well and see if people
understand that would mean the end of
Social Security and Medicare and all
these other things that we value they
also include putting voter ID in the US
Constitution and they are so radical
that they actually include revoking the
17th amendment now nobody's going to
remember what the 17th amendment is so
I'll just tell you real quick it was a
Progressive Era victory that let the
people directly elect our US senators
instead of having them selected by state
senators use right used to be appointed
exactly and the state government is the
easiest for corporations to capture in
the coat
that work knows this and they've been
capitalizing on it they now control 30
states and they're essentially putting a
chokehold around progressive policy
nationally and in the states at the
local level with something called
preemption